The answer happens to be no.
If I draw the original blue data points, the data is indeed linear,
but this data point over here of a house of size 2100 square feet
sold remarkably cheap, so we get the point right over here.
Similarly, the house of size 1300 square feet sold for a lot.
Both of these data points are outliers.
We'll talk about outliers later.
There is clearly no way to fit a linear function through all those data points.
I would even question that this wicked kind of function that I drew is a good
accurate representation of the relationship between size and price.
You would not expect that as you go south of 1500 square feet
that the price would rapidly increase and then decrease again
because there is likely nothing special about small houses than justifies the price over here.